foreign
[Music]
you know collectively earning that you
know how many Yachts can they need you
know
to water
ski behind it you know I mean it's just
crazy you know
all right we're doing Today's Show
in honor of John fetterman I
put on my uh my hoodie
um the old hoodie from Penn State from
about 25 years ago it's ripped into some
weird places I don't really know why
now
we're just happy to be here uh doing a
show for you guys today
uh this is this is the way we're gonna
do the Shelf now and I'll I'll tell you
the news the way I always do with papers
and stuff
uh you know rich people and poor people
and
yeah you know feel good you know the big
great you know with the Senate and you
know it's all good
can you imagine if I was dressed like
this to do a show
where I'm supposed to communicate the
news to you in somewhat of a sensible
way if I dress like this not only this
by the way I really went all out today
so this is of course in honor of John
Federman I found the rattiest sweatshirt
I could find in my house this is uh this
is David sweatshirt from Penn State from
like 25 20 years ago or something it's
ratty it's disgusting I don't know why
it's ripped like this I mean I don't
know what he was doing in college that
makes me wonder uh but I also I went
above and beyond because it's not just
of course the ratty hoodie the stinky
ratty hoodie that John Federman wears he
also wears shorts so I put on
these pink shorts now these are
obviously this is Marine layer these are
nice shorts very soft and comfortable
way nicer than anything John fetterman
would wear but I put pink on in honor of
all of our trans brothers and sisters in
the Senate and the Congress there are
obviously six or seven of them I don't
have to list them out you can figure out
who they are uh but look I I uh we're
gonna do a show we're going to do a
regular show but I honestly cannot do a
show like this so can you bear with us
give me just 30 seconds or so I'll be
right back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
people I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's September 20th 2023 if you
haven't subscribed please do so over on
Rumble locals and Spotify just search
Reuben report tap that notification Bell
maybe you'll see our videos and as
always we've got a post game wrap up at
reubenreport.locals.com I feel much
better who would want to listen to a
person dressed like that for the record
let's just not let's just bust the
illusion right now I am still in the
shorts I forgot my pants I forgot my
pants okay all right it is what it is
just bear with me today uh but really
like joking aside with these people the
clips yesterday really caught fire
especially on Twitter the the fetterman
stuff and it's just like enough enough
lowest common denominator related to
absolutely everything enough destroying
all of our Norms it doesn't mean you're
like some pretty conservative and I have
to always be dressed a certain way and I
have rules for everything no if we
should have basic standards and you
would not watch this show if I dressed
like a common bum and we shouldn't have
Senators that do that either but that's
not exactly what our show is about we do
have some bum related people uh but it
is further about that lowest common
denominator thing because we seem to be
governed and it's not just us here in
the United States by a series of people
who sometimes they say the right thing
and we kind of like them while they're
saying the right thing but then they
seem to always govern the wrong way so
we're going to do a whole bunch here
about immigration there's a massive
Fiasco happening in Italy right now but
of course we know it's happening right
here in the United States at our
Southern border and now leaking into
many of our cities and then I'm going to
connect that with sort of how Hollywood
and the the pundit class and the
celebrity class and the Hollywood Elite
I suppose more than anything uh frame
the issues for us us culturally so none
of us actually know how to fight the
problems when they arrive on our
doorstep and in this case at least at
the immigration level and the amount of
people coming into America right now
they are at our doorstep for real it
also Keeps Us distracted from the real
issues so let's talk about all that but
first virtual well guys Congress once
again has allowed itself to be pushed
into appeasing the administration and
raising the debt ceiling for the 79th
time Paving the way for continued
Reckless spending and further
devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket how
are you protecting your savings times
like this are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold and here's the easiest way
to do it guys Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold you don't pay a penny out of
pocket and as bricks that's Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa band
together against the dollar more and
more central banks are Diversified you
know what you're they're buying
God you're good yeah it's gold follow
their lead visit birchgold.com Dave for
your free info kid on gold there's no
obligation just information with an A
plus rating With Better Business Bureau
and thousands of happy customers Birch
gold can help you protect your savings
as well birchgold.com
and now back to me okay this show today
is going to be a little bit all over the
place but for those of you who are
clever for those of you who can find
little Easter eggs that who want to
follow me along this ride I think you
will see how we bring this thing home I
want to start with a clip uh this is
from January of 23 so beginning of this
year this is comedian Louis CK on Joe
Rogan and you might go Dave why are you
starting us off with a clip from a
comedian you know about nine months ago
well it was making the rounds yesterday
all over Twitter this clip was blowing
up and it was blowing up because of the
immigration crisis that we have in our
country right now and this idea that we
should have open borders and let
everyone in we're also systemically
racist but everyone should come here and
share in the in the Tyranny and all that
stuff anyway this clip of Louis CK on
Joe Rogan he's explaining why he thinks
we should have open borders and everyone
should come to America and that'll kind
of frame us for the rest of the show
today my feeling is they should open it
the border is let them pour it let
everybody pour in and and then the
answer which is well then there will be
all these problems yes there should be
it shouldn't be so great here is what
I'm saying in America it shouldn't be
it's a weird thing to sequester a
certain group of people and try to keep
upping their lifespan and their
lifestyle
and just keep trying to increase that
for this group of people and then
everyone's and then this pressure of
people trying to come in so they can
enjoy it and then it gets worse and
worse down here I mean I'm not Canada
it's really just from down here uh
there's something wrong with that that's
not a system that's working
and it forces people to do cruel things
to other people there's a lot of people
that die so Americans can be safe
they're just dying you know weddings
that are drone bombed in Yemen because
the guy said something that might have
resulted in American
insecurity not even like definite
American deaths but like just so we can
breathe a little easier folks die
and folks do labor in unsafe places so
that we can keep the prices where we
like them there's so much about American
life that other people pay for that's
part of it but also it's not good for us
either it's not a good way to live in a
gated community you know if if you let
folks pour in like any other wave it'll
kind of slosh and then y'all just things
will be different
I I don't know like there what'll really
happen a bunch of people like well they
just come with knives and start killing
everybody I don't think so uh Yes
actually we'll show you some video of
what's going on in Italy in just a
moment uh look first off I don't want to
specifically make this about Louis CK
the man Louis CK it's more about the
ideas that are promulgated throughout
Hollywood and Rogan just kind of sits
there listening to him as if any of that
made any sense so it's not about Louie
specifically but they're this is what
sort of mainstream leftist liberal group
think is oh everyone should just come
here we don't want to be mean to anyone
and not let them in here but of course
these are the same people who will tell
you that America is systemically racist
and how horrible we are in capitalism's
evil and all that yet still everybody
wants to come here and nobody wants to
leave uh Louis CK is worth about 35
million we did a quick check on that and
he says that you know people shouldn't
live in gated communities everyone in
Hollywood basically lives in a gated
community or has private security
etc etc I am going to guess and this is
then I will move on past Louis
specifically that he has a gate at his
house and he likely has security with
him when he travels and all of those
things so nothing this is what they do
it's standard 101 stuff with leftists on
almost everything it kind of sounds nice
but they would never live their life
that way wherever he lives I'm guessing
he lives in Beverly Hills or in you know
do we know he lives in Manhattan like I
am guarantee you he lives in a doorman
building with a lot of security at that
at that gate downstairs at that big door
downstairs like without question and for
good reason and I don't begrudge him
that but all of these people this is
what they do we should have an open
border everyone should come nobody's
illegal right no human is illegal I'm
gonna put a sign in my yard of course my
yard has a fence in front of it and we
have armed security and you know a dog
and electric stuff and all that but I
put a sign so I'm obviously nice trans
rights man
it's all moronic and then what happens
what happens well over time people in a
country that hear this and this is why
politics is Downstream from culture when
your entire
cultural apparatus teaches you the wrong
ideas teaches you that you don't know
between men and women two plus two now
equals five all of the wrong things then
over time you elect the wrong people and
then the policies are wrong and you
literally destroy Freedom right weak
times create strong men strong men
create good societies good societies
create weak men and then the cycle
continues right so with this borders
thing that we'll get to what's going on
in America in Italy right now this is
absolutely insane what is going there is
a small island in Italy Italy has a
couple small Islands uh not this one in
this case is not Sicily where Sophia
Petrillo is from this is from an island
called lampedusa Italy it has a
population of 6 000 people I want to
show you this tweet here from end
wokeness
look at this in a single day 5 000
illegals stormed an island with a
population of six thousand it's not
immigration it's Invasion so there you
can see it there's the official it's
Wikipedia but we did double check it the
island itself has about 6 000 native
people who live there uh and I think
that is from the guardian over 5 000
illegal immigrants storm Italian island
on a single day no now they're saying
it's about eight thousand right so now
they've eclipsed the amount of people
who are the natives to the island and
they have let them there it's it's also
very bizarre and we'll try to find out
more about this over the next couple
days because you know about six months
ago Italy elected uh Maloney who she was
coming across as sort of the Trump very
strong kind of populist right wing we
have a culture to defend we have borders
to defend and everything else this is
her moment this is her moment right now
so we will see what happens but anyway
the island now an island of 6 000
natives six thousand Italians who have a
culture and a lifestyle and food which
is usually pretty good uh they now have
8 000 people on this island that have
nothing in common with them right here's
a bunch of these people arriving on the
island
foreign
I want to be very clear about something
before Media Matters and the rest of the
Daily Beast huffpo losers come after me
this has nothing to do with race or
racism if it was 8 000 people who were
all white coming from Poland it would
still be a problem there is a reason for
the nation-state right that's something
that Louis C.K doesn't understand we all
live in a nation and that Nation sets
borders and within those borders it has
a certain policy related to Economic
Policy related to speech related to
whatever now not all of those things are
equal right if you live in a western
country you probably live in a Freer
place than if you live in a communist
country but China as a nation sets
policy for the Chinese and sets a border
policy and the United States sets a
border policy we don't actually uh you
know defend our border policy but but
that's something different but this has
nothing to do with race what this has to
do with is how can a functioning society
exist if anyone can just be part of it
at any time and if nobody will protect
the border so anyone can just show up
and start mooching off the system and
basically taking over the town so check
out this video of these new illegal
immigrants these are not migrants these
are not whatever nice word they want to
use of the day to confuse you illegal
immigrants basically just taking over
the entire town on this tiny Island
[Music]
stop
foreign
guys this has nothing to do with race
and I don't think inherently all of
those people are evil people or they're
up to no good or they want to rape or
pillage or anything else but imagine if
you were the the mother there was a
young mother there probably in her 20s
pushing that stroller with that little
girl and you live on this tiny little
island you know where the local stores
are and everything else you just live
your kind of quiet life and then one day
8 000 people show up more than the
current population of the island and
they have nothing to do right they don't
have jobs so they're just kind of
hanging out and then what happens when a
bunch of guys and isn't it interesting
that it's all guys who look like they're
in their early to mid 20s where are all
the girls where are the old women
where's Grandma and Grandpa and
everybody else it's all young men
how do you think she feels when she's
pushing that stroller down that little
Street there on that island you think
she feels safe and actually is she safe
and again it has nothing to do with race
but a bunch of young guys in their 20s
with no jobs nothing to do sitting
around you think they might start
getting into trouble you think drugs
might start getting involved you think
some petty theft that men some much
worse crime you think that might be
happening this is a bit of a throwaway
but here's something that happened in
Sweden Switzerland yesterday and for
some reason Phoenix wanted me to show it
to you
[Music]
it's that was just because you have a
soft spot for Italy and you wanted
people to see that it's not so great in
Switzerland either yeah so just like
these things are just happening they are
just happening and until we all say
enough Maloney this is uh what's her
name Georgia Maloney Georgia money right
this is your moment like you have a you
have a very brief window right now get
those people off that Island
you don't have to go home but you cannot
stay here it is as simple as that and we
better start doing that in the United
States too you know the weird thing is
Europe was doing this 10 years ago right
letting in all these syrians and libyans
and all of these people from all of
these different places and we can
address that perhaps it is some of the
policies of the United States and the
Western Nations and
Europe Etc who have caused the upheaval
that leads to the mass migration but
that doesn't mean you just fall on the
sword and give up your country Germany
is suffering from that right now their
social services are absolutely
collapsing because of that and they're
not the only one in the west so Italy
which seemed like it was about to kind
of turn around right and be like no we
will protect we will protect this you
cannot have all our pasta or our risotto
we are protecting it we like our
bucatini that wasn't an Italian accent
but you get the point it seems like
they're going down the wrong path too uh
but okay let's bring this to the United
States because guys like Louis C.K but
again this is the Hollywood Elite nobody
should be illegal or that what the other
thing they do is they say nobody should
be legal then all these people start
coming and then we get people like uh
you know mayorkus and our politicians
and our leaders of some sort who get up
there and say no no the border is safe
right uh Kamala Harris goes on every TV
show The Border is safe the Border has
never been safer safer well here's the
Border
uh Emily up here you go you got you got
people coming in now take a look at this
a lot of young adult men being let
through now
so every person who was just let through
is a uh appears to be a single adult
male Brian if we can turn around really
quick I don't know if they're all with
the same group let me try to ask them
really quick
you're from Ghana okay
you're from Haiti you're from Haiti so
all right there we are that's Bill
malugin who does a really fine job for
Fox News and Fox news by the way is the
only uh mainstream media covering this
at all there is a it's an invasion it's
an actual Invasion those guys have no
right to be in the United States do we
have a border or do we not if you don't
have a border you are not a country why
are a bunch of guys from Ghana and again
it's all guys all in their 20s wandering
through Mexico and then we have our
immigration agents right we have our
officers literally opening the door for
him go on in we'll could you just wait
if they think it's like a freaking ride
at Disneyland oh well we let in eight
people we gotta wait for this ride to go
around then we'll let you guys in just
give them a second the bathrooms are
over there why don't you get some cotton
candy while you're waiting it's
absolutely insane and then what's
happening is they're being exported
throughout the country so you know where
they're ending up right now they're
ending up in uh well in many places but
one of them is San Diego perhaps one of
the most beautiful places in all despite
the fact that it's in California in all
of the United States a place where it is
78 to 81 every day nobody cares about
anything other than eating fish tacos
and getting a good tan well here's San
Diego yesterday take a look at this
video out of San Diego yesterday
afternoon what you're looking at is
three unmarked white border patrol buses
they pull up and they start releasing
several hundred illegal immigrants to
City streaks and sidewalks in San Diego
across from a Transit terminal people
were on this bus from as far away as
China and Pakistan and keep in mind
these buses are not from Texas they're
not Greg Abbott's buses these are the
Biden administration's buses this is
border patrol Mass releasing people you
can see handfuls of them are standing
around not knowing where they are what
to do where to go next and there was a
remarkable exchange between one migrant
and a border patrol agent as he asked
the agent hey am I okay to travel to
Chicago and the agent says yep you're
good to go take a listen
freedom
I just want to say to that specific
illegal immigrant dude don't go to
Chicago you're gonna get shot
I don't know what was going on in Ghana
okay I have no idea I assure you Chicago
is no better you stay in San Diego fish
tacos
fish tacos
um this is insane three buses and did
you catch that this is not evil Greg
Abbott in Texas doing this right even
though it's not Greg Abbott's job to
protect the Border it's the federal
government's job to protect the Border
it's not Greg Abbott doing it it is the
homeland security right it's the federal
government that's just saying come on in
we're not doing our job and we'll give
you a free ride and dump you into San
Diego
it is an invasion it is intentional I
don't know how to see it any other way
the other place that this is happening
at a crazy rate is New York City and we
covered over the last two weeks how Eric
Adams the mayor of New York City who is
a leftist buffoon although he wears well
tailored suits that's nice at least he's
no fetterman in that regard his his
suits do fit well but he has let in 10
000 people a month the city is being
overrun they are putting uh instead of
having tourists in hotels that's the way
it used to be in the greatest city in
the world they are over running hotels
the Roosevelt Hotel which is one of the
most legendary hotels literally in the
world certainly was one of the top three
hotels in New York City for decades is
now basically a mass migrant shelter and
the people of New York City have had it
check this out from Fox I have to spend
time hundreds of dollars to get their
school supplies
they're coming here not vaccinated we
just had a coveted crisis they shut our
businesses down yes they fired teachers
fire department for not getting
vaccinated who do you think needs to do
more we hear from the mayor of New York
who says he's doing everything it can
every day as migrants continue to come
in we are we are I will say too we're
live on air so uh but you know what do
you think about what the mayor's doing
and what should the president and the
White House be doing
this is up to us this is up to each and
every one of us to stand up nobody's
coming here for us right we're here for
ourselves if we don't get up and fight
for our city nobody's coming for us
they're coming and destroy it the reason
why they're here is to steal our votes
that that is a good man
um I have no doubt The Machine's gonna
probably come after him and he'll you
know someone will try to get him fired
from his job if anyone knows who he is
if there's anything I can do to help him
I mean I feel for that I lived in that
City for 20 years I love that City I've
told you guys many times and I've
written about in my books there were
times in New York City Manhattan in the
boroughs that my family had upwards of
like 60 70 people living in New York
City
um there's one I got one cousin left as
far as I know uh because everybody has
fled the last ones to flee were my my
sister and brother and their three kids
now living in the Free State of Florida
surprise surprise uh when he says that
no one's come and help him he's damn
well right nobody no one in that city is
coming to help him Rudy Giuliani has not
taken over again unfortunately I think
he'd like to probably if he was a little
younger but nobody's going to save them
there and by the way the mayor is not
the person that can save you because it
has to come from the federal government
from stopping these people coming in the
first place but New York city is in an
absolute free fall I also love how the
host on Fox the guy says on the
side you heard the guy go slow the
she's like we're on we're on TV please
everyone calm down the city's being
overrun uh zombie apocalypse what do you
watch your language
anyway here's mayor Adams on what's
going on and remember this is the same
guy who gave a press conference two
weeks ago basically saying the sky is
falling they're all screwed I wish I
knew who was in in charge
but we cannot ignore the fact we spend
two billion dollars already we're
projected to spend five billion dollars
that money is going to come from
somewhere we made great strides of
supporting foster care children putting
money into housing putting money into
low-income New Yorkers and really
providing a way for those migrants that
are here if we don't receive help from
the federal government and additional
help from the state government then this
is going to come from somewhere and it's
going to hurt low-income New Yorkers and
I'm glad the Hispanic Congressional
Delegation came through they saw what we
were doing they walked out and stated
that you guys have really done a
dignified way of treating uh the
migrants and Asylum Seekers this is
wrong for the Michaels and Asylum
Seekers to be going through this and
it's wrong for long-term New Yorkers
that depend on this Revenue I have to go
back in November and find five billion
dollars out of our budget this is just
not right to this to the city
off man I I have just had it with
these people I really have he has
destroyed New York City little credit to
socialist Bill de Blasio before him but
you see even when at the end there he's
trying to like lay out his concern he's
he mentions the illegal immigrants
before he mentions the native New
Yorkers Native New Yorker great song by
Frankie Valli by the way
um it's just so absolutely incredible he
deserves no sympathy the only people I
have any sympathy with are the actual OG
New Yorkers who have to put up with
these morons and unfortunately a lot of
them voted it in too but I still have
sympathy for the people that are trying
to own a business there and raise a
family there and everything else if you
are sane you just have to get out but
the idea that oh no the federal
government has to come in and help him
now what he means by that is me and
these guys and you watching this you
should pay more can we just get more
money for this problem maybe we could
put an extra floor on the Roosevelt
Hotel we could expand the rooms a little
bit you know these poor illegal
immigrants from Ghana they need room
service man get them some Lobster
well anyway if there's a crisis in New
York City you know AOC is not too far
away and here she is trying to explain
why we need more care and hand-holding
and housing and help for these people
fortunately the people listening to her
weren't really having it ultimately I
think that there are three points of
consensus here that are very important
in getting a solution to this issue the
first is that there is there is
consensus here across geography and
States
um increased Federal resources to cities
and municipalities dealing with this
issue the second is to allow for work
authorizations so that the folks in here
can get to work and start supporting
themselves as soon as possible they are
prevented from getting jobs they are
prevented from employment and that is
part of the strain on our public system
the faster that folks can access the
work that they're asking for legally the
better we can solve this problem and the
third is extension of temporary protect
status
are the largest
popular arriving here so with that we
thank you all
I really I already dropped the F-bomb
once I can't even say what I'm thinking
about her like it is just incredible
first off there there is consensus
amongst the people here we should have
more Federal resources oh I'm shocked
Democrat politician there's consensus
that someone should give us more money
if we just had more money we could solve
this problem we don't have enough money
could someone please write us a check
that's one thing maybe she should talk
to zielinski I heard he's doing okay
these days uh then her thing that we
just need a work authorization situation
these people need jobs no they need to
leave you cannot stay here you are
illegal you just wandered in some
douchebag at the border let you in and
he should probably be fired or his boss
should be fired but you gotta go you
can't stay here but this idea that they
need jobs this is the same Dullard
this is the same Dopey dingbat socialist
AOC who when Amazon tried to bring
40 000 jobs to Queens right they were
going to bring it to the New York City
area she fought Amazon because she
doesn't like big companies right she
doesn't like giant corporations so 40
000 jobs that maybe these people could
have got I wouldn't have been for that
it doesn't really make sense but if she
cared about jobs she wouldn't be
fighting corporations that try to bring
jobs and health care and everything else
liar buffoon so how did we end up
in this situation where we are governed
by people like or at least if you live
in New York you're governed by people
like AOC you're governed by Eric Adams
how did we end up in a situation where
people can turn on the TV every day and
see illegals wandering in and be like
how can I help them
how did we end up there well there has
been a culture War raging for many many
years and this one this segment and the
next two segments actually don't give me
any great pleasure because I'm going to
talk about a couple people who I've
really admired and liked in a lot of
ways I'm gonna talk about Howard Stern
for a second because he had a clip now
it's interesting because Howard Stern
was the he was the king of radio he used
to call himself the king of media Howard
Stern
again I grew up in New York City I used
to listen to him when he was on what was
it 92.3 if I'm not mistaken or 90s what
was it what was his it was W well
eventually he was on wnbc but whatever
it was when he was on AM radio in in New
York City and and became absolutely huge
eventually he went to SiriusXM it's a
little bizarre because it's hard to tell
if he has any cultural irrelevance
anymore other than he says stupid things
every now and again and then people
respond to it anyway he went after
Lauren bobert because you know the other
day Lauren bobert got her boob squeezed
and people were freaking out and you
know again some people like squeezing
boobs some chicks like getting the boob
squeezed we can debate all about that
until the cows come home
um but but uh Howard Stern went off on
Lauren bobert you'll see how I'm
connecting this to everything else go
Lauren bolbert is a disgrace to this
country not because of the video you are
100 right forget the politics she's in a
titty dress if you saw the video she's
in a titty dress she's with some dude
looks like she's you know obviously
vaping but also looks like she might be
grabbing his penis during uh Beetlejuice
and uh and he's playing with her she's a
sexy play it's a very erotic play
evidently I remember the movie it was
nothing sexy about it you didn't grab
anybody during the movie I guess the
play is much hotter but uh but she was
wearing a tight titty dress uh I I've
seen porn stars wear more
okay so I want to explain how I'm
linking this all together just quickly
on Howard Stern you know my first gig
really my first sort of paying like
legit media gig was at SiriusXM I had a
weekly Sunday show at SiriusXM Howard
had his own Wing over there serious and
then the rest virtually everybody else
you know there's a hundred other serious
channels sports channels lifestyle
channels celebrity channels everything
else we were all on another side it's
him but I always wanted to say hi to him
and see him I've had many dreams in my
life that I would be on Howard Stern
when I wrote my two books the only show
that I asked my agents to get me on I
didn't care about any other show was
Howard Stern never happened does it
doesn't matter I've lost a lot of
respect for him over the years his covid
stuff has been insane his politics are
all completely just standard leftist
backwards whatever but the way I'm
linking this to everything else is and
and it's sort of like the Louis CK thing
are comedians our radio guys our our
cultural uh the cultural people who put
things together that make us start
thinking things it's like Howard Stern
you've been like the most over-the-top
over-sexed whatever and I'm not I don't
even I don't think sex is bad I'm not
even judging you for that but that that
now she got her boobs squeezed and yes
she shouldn't have done it at
Beetlejuice there's something just funny
about that in and of itself and The
Vaping or whatever but like that you sit
there in Judgment of her as if she's the
problem with Society she's actually been
a pretty good legislature legislator
pretty good congresswoman for uh for
Colorado and and Denver's a huge
freaking mess but she's done a pretty
decent job especially on the gun front
but anyway Howard Stern this guy did you
guys see the movie did you see private
parts of the movie did you ever see it
it's actually a pretty good movie but
one of the things that Howard Stern
actually did when he wants to talk about
degeneracy and everything else live on
air once on AM radio he had a woman call
in I think she was a porn star and he
had her sit on a giant speaker right and
he turned the bass all the way up and
then he went like this
for like three minutes in a row on air
while she was sitting on the speaker
with the bass up so that she would have
an orgasm Lauren bobert got her boob
squeezed and there's a real problem
this is probably the weirdest show we've
ever done anyway Ben Shapiro wasn't
having it with Howard Stern he made the
point uh Howard Stern spent his entire
career degrading and humiliating women
but he's off the hook because he mirrors
all the politics of the left that that
really is the point here right you can
always be wrong about everything you
could be wrong about kovid you could be
wrong about
immigration you can be wrong about
absolutely every policy but if you just
repeat the talking points of the left
the system will always protect you uh
it's very rare that you can abuse the
system to the point that it will kick
you out although every now and again it
does happen and Howard Stern this this
is another clip that was sort of related
to all of this Howard Stern did once
interview Harvey Weinstein before the
whole thing blew up and uh take a listen
to this why not stay single I gotta
figure every Starlet in Hollywood wanted
at least below you you know what I'm
saying did you did you ever get to
experience the I'm going to say the
Mogul aspect I mean do a little Coke you
know hang out with uh you know I don't
know uh Julia Roberts give you a
something you never got any of that
Howard as you know only too well it
doesn't work that way it doesn't really
I'll tell you who it works that way for
it works the way for the actors you know
producers every girl knows that that if
she's a competent actress if she could
get on your good side you could make her
a star over night don't tell me
it doesn't matter I wish I wish the
movies are too expensive the risks are
too great it doesn't happen you can't
walk into the room pull your pants off
and say okay
all right so first off obviously
Weinstein is lying there and and again
I'm only bringing this up because look I
I don't care about people doing drugs
privately I don't care about people
getting handjobs everyone I know has
gotten a from Julia Roberts I
mean come on
Brock was like yeah right well one time
yes I
the point is that he's on one hand these
are the cultural taste makers and when
you're a leftist you can do and say
anything and you're protected and when
you're not they'll destroy you so
bobert got her boob squeezed we gotta
take her out Howard Stern's been doing
this forever just one more kind of
disgusting one from from Howard Stern as
long as we're we're doing this this is
the day after the Columbine shooting
it's a bunch of chaos shooting and boy
bunch of good-looking girls go to that
school that guy was right the guy who
called him he was a little too excited
but he was like it was like really good
looking girls running out of there with
their hands over their heads yeah I'd
say the bomb teams are still working did
those kids try to have sex with any of
the good-looking girls they didn't even
do that
at least if you're gonna go kill
yourself and kill all the kids like why
wouldn't you have some sex
these guys were really against the good
looking girls because the good looking
girls
actually good looking girls would be
begging them to live and they go you
don't have to beg because you're gonna
be dead in a minute just don't cry don't
cry do you see my point do you see why
maybe we need to fix culture I'm not
against sex that gets drugs in the
privacy of your own home I'm not against
any of those things but do you see
that's the day after Columbine and he's
somehow talking about that these guys
should have been banging these girls
instead of shooting them I mean there's
I suppose a degree of Truth into that
but you get the point you get the point
like we've we've sort of destroyed our
culture to the point that you could be
wrong about everything and you're you're
kind of elated for it you're kind of
inflated for it not only you're kind of
inflated for it it's a problem it's a
problem so I I this this really is a
show that will go down in my mind
forever because the next guy I want to
talk about is genuinely I told you about
Howard Stern was a hero of mine for a
while and he's been a huge cultural
taste maker well now another one this is
a story that just came out because you
know there's this uh biography that just
it just came out or it's coming out next
week it just came out a week ago of Eli
Elon Musk and in the biography there is
a story about when Elon Musk met Larry
David Larry David in some ways is
probably my biggest comic icon in that
he created uh Seinfeld with Jerry
Seinfeld the character of George is
based on him I don't know that any show
affected me more than Seinfeld in terms
of like comedy and I lived in New York
City like basically a block away from
where Jerry lived in real life which was
like two blocks away from where he lived
on the show and that whole thing was my
life in many ways for 15 or 20 years he
then obviously went on to create Curb
Your Enthusiasm but he is like a crazy
crazy leftist which he kind of
acknowledges by the way on the show
which is at least I I will give him
credit for that but but I love this guy
in terms of the art right so I guess
what I'm talking about today is sort of
separating the art from the artist and
it can be very very hard to do but
anyway a story about Larry David meeting
Elon Musk uh was out in this
autobiography in the New York Post
covered it and I thought it was kind of
interesting comedian Larry David
reportedly wanted Elon Musk to curb his
enthusiasm for the Republican party in a
scene that could have easily come from
David's HBO hit show The irascible
Seinfeld co-creator confronted the Tesla
boss at a super agent at super agent Ari
Emmanuel's star-studded wedding in San
Tropez France last year David and
Emmanuel client who officiated the
nuptials between the talent agent and
fashion designer Sarah stoutinger was
seated at a table that included musk
according to author Walter Isaacson in
his new biography titled Elon Musk
Isaacson wrote that David seemed to be
fuming according to Isaacson David S
musk do you just want to murder kids in
school David appeared to be referencing
the mass shooter in Uvalde Texas which
claimed the lives of 19 children and two
teachers the killings took place just
four days before the May 28th wedding no
no musk who was said to be baffled and
annoyed replied I'm anti-kid murder the
Mogul reportedly told David then how
could you vote Republican Dave David
repeatedly
sorry reportedly asked musk Isaacson
wrote that David confirmed to him the
details of the reported encounter so
again do you see what I'm trying to do
here I don't want to go after Larry
David I would love to meet Larry David
and have a stop and chat as he would say
okay but these people that are somehow
in charge of our culture get all of the
important things wrong and then it leads
to bad politics so that Larry David
would be at a wedding in San Jose France
one of the most beautiful places in the
world surrounded by all rich and
beautiful people sitting at a table with
Elon Musk a billionaire yelling at him
because of his support for Republicans
which Elon Musk is and even a republican
he's we've discussed it on the show many
times he's basically just a disaffected
liberal and his entire life he only
voted for Democrats until the last
election but Larry David felt the
righteous indignation to basically say
you want to kill kids while at Ari
Emmanuel's wedding
you got it anyway they discussed this on
The View
so of course Joy Behar had to defend
Larry David and disagree with you sonny
because I actually see Alyssa's Point
here I think there's a spectrum of
people that actually have nuanced views
on this is a complicated matter and what
Larry David did what I'm witnessing here
would be just a gotcha moment there's no
way to respond there's no way one I
don't think anyone's for murdering
children so that's just an over-the-top
statement and how are you going to then
dive into what you believe your gun
stance because we only get two parties
to pick from and sometimes they both
suck a little and so not equally so but
to me everyone has different reasons
they go for which party to reduce it
just to if you vote this way then you
must be this I just think that's
reductive Democrats vote to get rid of
these these rifles and the Republicans
don't that's all we're saying
oh joy oh joyless brainless Joy um first
off the blonde whose name I always
forget and it's not worth knowing she
actually made sense she actually made
sense right like everything she said
there fully made sense credit to
nameless blonde person with Joy Behar oh
it's the Democrats who just want to do
the Democrats just want to take guns
away from law-abiding citizens so
obviously they're the good guys here
it's very bizarre because none of these
shootings are ever done by members of
the NRA there are good guys who kill bad
guys with gun these are always people
with mental health problems remember
that while they shooting that was one of
the most Twisted ones that we that we've
had in America and I think it was
Ultimate I think it was six uh 17 kids I
mean elementary school kids were killed
and two teachers if I'm not mistaken
that was the the shooting that the next
day uh Joy another Joy uh Joy Reid went
on MSNBC and said that this was not a
mental health issue this was a gun issue
and it's like that like the level and
that's the confusion that Joy Behar and
Joy Reed have I don't know what it is
with the name Joy but like first off if
you take more guns away then people
can't protect themselves and then bad
guys will be emboldened also the more
laws you have bad guys generally don't
abide by laws right Chicago has the most
strictest gun laws in the nation and
also the most shootings again that poor
guy from Ghana is probably going to be
shot this weekend and I blame that on
the Democrat
um
so Joy it's Avi Joy either Joy it's
obviously it's a mental health issue
it's a prescription drug issue it's a
societal issue it's a it's what you
people have done with our schools so
kids are confused about their gender and
what the very nature of reality is
that's what it is on everything else
anyway as if you as if Joy Behar and her
just like just like the simple well they
want to do something about guns so
they're they're the good guys as if that
like base level nonsensical useless
analyzation is worthy at all Sunny
Hosten actually doubled down on it
I mean as you seize the opportunity how
often is Larry David going to be sitting
next to to Elon Musk ask who and it says
well legitimate question you know
Republicans whenever there's a school
shooting they don't want us to talk
about this is not the time to talk about
it well when is the time and so Larry
stepped up and talked about it four days
after Karen good for him listen I
completely agree with you I I think you
take the opportunity to call people on
it AR-15s are weapons of mass
destruction that should happen took
place in anyone's hands in this country
and if you vote Republican I believe
that you are complicit in that unless
you are actively working day and night
to change that within your party it
strikes me that Elon Musk is a little
more interested in his money he's a
little more interested in Tesla he's
more interested in Neo-Nazi platforming
on Twitter or X or whatever the heck
because I can't use it anymore because
I've been suspended from it and I don't
even know why and I just think that you
know you have to really think when you
align yourself with a party as to what
that party is doing for you you your
family your country and the Republicans
in my opinion right should be ashamed of
what the executive who hired her at ABC
should be ashamed everything she said
there was backwards from the truth and
again this thing that yes the Elon Musk
is making Twitter or X for neo-nazis
Sonny Hassan's been been banned from
Twitter suspended from Twitter is that
right is that right where we've got 10
computers working on that right now by
the way the Uvalde shooter who we
referenced before and that's what this
was all about that's what Larry David
was pissed off about at Elon Musk over
as if Elon Musk has anything to do with
you while they shooting or anything else
while they shoot her passed a federal
background check to get gun okay he got
the gun legally we do have checks and
you're going to have there's no such
thing as a perfect system humans are
imperfect so we build imperfect systems
and I'm being told on the fly right now
that there is nothing to suggest that
Sonny Hosten has been banned or
suspended she's on Twitter right now so
okay so that was yesterday's view I
don't know what the high hell she was
talking about
which that should just be that goes in
perpetuity if somebody hasn't said
something I don't know what the hell
she's talking about
anyway what is the left and the and it's
not even just the left it's like this
whole cultural blob of black what is its
sort of
um what is its main mission its main
mission seems to be keeping a whole
bunch of us stupid and scared right
we're scared that random people are
gonna come for are going to shoot us
we're scared that all all of the stuff
right the Republicans are going to bring
the white supremacists here and then
Elon Musk will be Hitler too I don't
know it's all ridiculous uh but I wanted
to throw back to some of the ways that
they scare you we should not forget when
we're talking about people who just
operate on fear uh one of truly the
worst most inauthentic leaders in all of
the West probably the most you already
know who I'm talking about Justin
Trudeau of Canada uh here he is in 2021
uh talking about kids and covid and
vaccines and how to how to keep your
freedoms because apparently he thinks he
has the keys to those freedoms
if you've done the right thing and
gotten vaccinated you deserve the
freedom to be safe from covet 19. to
have your kids safe from covet to get
back to the things you love
and if you haven't gotten your shots yet
but want to travel this winter let's be
clear
there will only be a few extremely
narrow exceptions like a valid medical
condition
for the vast vast majority of people the
rules are very simple
to travel you've got to be vaccinated
these travel measures along with
mandatory vaccination for federal
employees are some of the strongest in
the world
because when it comes to keeping you and
your family safe when it comes to
avoiding lockdowns for everyone this is
no time for half measures
already we're delivering on the first of
our vaccine commitments and in the weeks
to come we'll get the job done on a
vaccine passport for international
travel we'll be there to foot the bill
for provinces and territories that roll
out proof of vaccination programs and
we'll introduce legislation to make it a
criminal offense to threaten or harass
health care workers how insane is that
like two years ago that's what that guy
was doing
and that's what he did to Canada and
that led to the trucker Convoy that then
he suspended people's bank accounts and
arrested people who just wanted to live
freely all because of a vaccine that
actually did not work and they damn well
know it and we'll get to that in just a
second if there is any justice in this
universe that man should spend the rest
of his life in jail I see no other way
around it he infringed on millions of
people's freedoms joyfully otherwise
will lock you down again you had no damn
right to do it in the first place but
speaking of awful leaders related to
that as you know in the last couple
weeks they seem to want to bring covid
back Dr Jill Biden got coveted and then
Joe Biden was supposed to wear a mask
but he decided not to because he's
better than you as a as a politician and
a Democrat especially uh and uh Whoopi
Goldberg who got it and Whoopi's
pregnant right isn't she pregnant with
five five babies isn't that what I heard
on something I heard that somewhere uh
anywhere anyway New York Governor Kathy
seaward Kathy hokel she is still
pushing the vaccine and listen just
really listen to this she's telling you
the last vaccine didn't work she's
telling you you got to get a new vaccine
tell everybody don't rely on the fact
that you had a vaccine in the past it
will not help you this time
oh you got the vax
the double Vex you got the booster you
know they spun you around in a
centrifuge and dumped goo all over you
and you're like no no do it again do it
again so it's fear mongering with
everything because if they can keep you
afraid all the time you will turn to
them but I recommend maybe we'll do a
Reuben report on locals we did it once
very early at the uh during covet we
were doing like movie nights together
maybe we'll watch V for Vendetta again
because if you remember Viva Vendetta I
don't know it's a spectacular movie if
you have not seen it done by the
Wachowski well I think they were
brothers at the time but now they're the
now they're sisters I guess they became
chicks or whatever which the other ones
they also did The Matrix and they did
Cloud Atlas and a bunch of great movies
they're great filmmakers regardless of
whether they have penises or not uh and
uh in in uh River Vendetta there's this
great moment where the you know the the
prime minister is losing control of the
city and he's screaming on a big screen
we must show them how much they need us
I think William Hurt is the actor he's
really great in it and that's what these
people are doing but it's not just
fear-mongering related to vaccines and
shootings and you know that the white
supremacists are gonna come get you it's
also that climate change is here the
climate is coming for you it's going to
drown or burn you perhaps ground and
burn you that would be a hell of a way
to go we'll all be dying in boiling hot
water or something like that uh and uh
zielinski Ukraine zielinski a man who is
enjoying the fruits of your labor as the
head of Ukraine uh he showed up it's a
middle of a war but he was able to show
up to the U.N yesterday they're having
their general assembly and uh he
lectured us about climate change
humanity is failing on his climate
policy objectives this means that
extreme weather will still impact the
normal Global Life and some evil state
will also mobilize its outcomes
and when people in the streets of New
York
and other cities of the world went out
on climate protest we all have seen them
I'm pretty sure he said the quiet part
out loud that some bad guy is going to
weaponize the outcome of climate change
like they're telling you they're telling
you we can create a situation where
you're going to think that the sky is
falling and we're going to weaponize it
we we hear the baddies that's how it
works but just think about this we're
told that this guy is in the midst of
what he's veering into World War III
he's out there he needs your money he
needs your weapons he needs your planes
by the way do we find that plane that
F-35 that went missing they did find it
where was it Jersey he was in Hackensack
where was it they found it in South so
it got lost in South Carolina they found
it in South Carolina that's exciting
look at that the government finding
something hot damn anyway the guys in
the midst of this war but he has time to
show up to New York City to lecture us
about climate change a completely
fabricated problem
anyway one more for you from the same
guy which is why he's not allowed on
mainstream media here's RFK Jr on what
totalitarian regimes are actually trying
to do
today particularly
we have the rise of all of these new
technologies for surveillance and
control we have ai technology which you
know is going to be
give us all these new difficulties we
have um we have facial recognitions
Technologies we have technologies that
can look through walls and find people
who are hiding in homes we have uh now
permits for 415 000 low altitude
satellites that will be able to look at
every square inch of the Earth every day
we all have GPS
on our watches and our cars that allow
the government to follow us all the time
we're carrying around cell phones that
allow not only corporations but the
government to listen every conversation
we have so the you know the potential
for excessive government power
and that the rise of this kind of what I
would call TurnKey totalitarianism if
they're if a totalitarian regime
ever gains control over our country the
level of control that they can impose
upon us uh will be you know it will be
irresistible
digital currencies and another thing and
you know now that you know they're of
course they try to get vaccine passports
um but digital currencies they can they
if you misbehave they can shut off your
bank account they can starve you that
they can you know kick you out of your
your house and this isn't theoretical
that's exactly what they did to the
truckers during the you know the
trucking protests in Canada
they shut down the bank accounts and
credit cards in the trucker so they
couldn't buy gas they couldn't pay their
alimonys they couldn't pay their
mortgages they couldn't buy food for
their children
and if government has the capacity to
you know to starve you that it has the
capacity to turn you into a slave really
important right now
we fortify our constitutional rights
make them impervious to any kind of
attack
talk about a crazy way of like threading
the needle on this show how bizarre is
it that his wife in real life is Cheryl
Hines who is married to Larry David on
Curb Your Enthusiasm where they're now
divorced in Curb Your Enthusiasm but
like what like a weird thing all that is
anyway
that's the guy that Jake Tapper on CNN
said he's too controversial to be
allowed to be interviewed on CNN right
that's the guy that the DNC will not
allow to debate that's the guy that if
he shows up in Iowa as we talked about
last week they will literally change all
of the votes from him to Joe Biden quite
literally if he campaigns there if you
step foot in Iowa because they don't
want a contested primary the votes will
all go to the incumbent Joe Biden so
that's what we're up against and uh I
guess although I did say some funny
things today this was pretty freaking
depressing
what are we having for lunch
go we're having sushi for lunch uh so
that's pretty good and uh I just want to
say that I didn't drone strike myself
and I love you guys and have a great day
everybody oh post game show
reubenreport.locals.com see you in 30
seconds adios
sounds like Protege I one one time for
13 days without sleeping and smoking
crack and drinking vodka exclusively
throughout that entire turn guys it's
probably smoked more parmesan cheese
than anyone what
I uh I'm abide and we cry too much yeah
I rode my bike over to a cemetery nearby
her boyfriend just died yeah I'll throw
in a wedding every now and then but
funerals are insane overwhelming grief
the chicks are so horny it's not even
fair yeah crazy horny grief turned into
a hope for a love grief is Nature's Most
Powerful aphrodisiac first in the
process Saturday I got one Saturday
you're coming with yeah
[Music]
thank you